فجاه استيقظ العالم ليجد اسعار السلع
والمواد الغذائيه عند على مستوى لها في
نصف قرن كان ذلك تحديدا في اثار مارس
الماضي بسبب التداعيات الاقتصاديه لحرب
روسيا على اوكرانيا وتفاقم معدلات التضخم
العالميه واستمرار ازمه سلاسل التوريد
وتظهر بيانات منظمه الاغذيه والزراعه
العالميه الفاو التابعه للامم المتحده ان
اسعار السلع الغذائيه قفزت خلال تلك
الفتره بقرابه 13% حيث تسببت الحرب في
عرقله الصادره الروسيه والاكرانيه وفي
مارس تجاوز مؤشر الفاول اسعار الغذاء الذي
يقيس السلعه الغذائيه الاكثر تداولا
عالميا
159 نقطه وهو اعلى مستوى له على الاطلاق
منذ بدء العمل به عام 1990
ففي اوكرانيا هو محصول الحبوب ب 20 في
المئه مقارنه بالمستواه العمل الماضي بعد
تقلص المساحات المزروعه بسبب الحرب
فالبلدان روسيا واوكرانيا من اكبر منتجي
ومصدر السلع الغذائيه على مستوى العالم اذ
تستحوذ روسيا وحدها على 11% من صادرات
القمح عالميا بينما تبلغ حصه اوكرانيا
خمسه في المئه من تلك الصادرات فضلا عن
14% من صادرات الذره ويؤكد البنك الدولي
ان اضطراب صادرات البلدين ادى الى تراجع
الملحوظ في حجم تجاره الدوليه رياح الازمه
وصلت الى منطقه الشرق الاوسط وشمال
افريقيا حيث ارتفعت اسعار المواد الغذائيه
الى اعلى مستوياتها في عشر سنوات فالدول
العربيه تستهلك ربع صادرات القمح العالميه
وكانت تستورد 60% من اجمالي احتياجاتها من
روسيا اوكرانيا لا سيما مصر اكبر مستورد
للقمح في العالم
المحصله ان البلدان العربيه اصبحت تعاني
من صعود قياسين لاسعار القمح بلغت نسبته
50% خلال العام الجاري ومما يفارقم الازمه
اتساعه حجم فجوه القمح بالمنطقه الى 50
مليون طن سنويا اكثر من ذلك فقد اصبحت
تكلفه استيراد القمح تعادل ضعف التقديرات
الوارده لها في موازنات الدول العربيه
وهكذا يطوي العالم صفحه عام 2022 وعدد
الجياع مرشح للصعود بعد ما وصل بنهايه
2021 الى 888 مليون شخص وفقا للامم
المتحده مئه وخمسون مليون منها هؤلاء القي
بهم في دوامه الجوع منذ اندلاع رائحه
كورونا عام 2019 اما في منطقه الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا فتشف منظمه الفاو ان
عدد الجياع يناهز
مليون شخص مع ارتفاع معدل الجوع باكثر من
90% منذ عام 2000